two runoff senate races heat up as
president trump arrives to campaign for
republicans in georgia
kovit continues to wash across america
with hypocrisy and heavy handedness
ruling the day
and joe biden demonstrates once again he
is not a moderate i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind
whenever you go online visit
expressvpn.com well we'll get to all the
news of the day and big news happening
over
the weekend first let's talk about the
best gift that you can get someone this
holiday season i'm talking about
steak delicious tender juicy
incredible steak now i know the omaha
steaks folks make incredible steak
because i'm a special person they
actually got me a specialized
kosher steak they sent it to me maybe a
year ago and they sent it to me it was
freeze
it was it was flash frozen and it was it
was easy to put in the freezer take it
out and grill
it is just unbelievable okay it's so
good it is so tender
it is so juicy every single bite is
unbelievable why
well because omaha steaks is the best of
the best right now you get yourself the
deluxe griller's assortment includes a
vast variety of entrees sides and
desserts it includes
omaha steak butchers cut filet mignons
these beauties are perfectly aged hand
carved famously fork tender
and all their steaks are perfectly aged
100 american grain finished steaks for
the ultimate in tenderness
juiciness and flavor it's a perfect
holiday gift to gift that your family
members will share
remember and love they'll be thinking of
you while they chow down on the greatest
stakes in existence right now
you can get the mouth-watering package
plus four free burgers and a free
digital meat thermometer and exclusive
price available only
to my listeners that's a discount of
over 50 percent go to omahastakes.com
enter code shapiro into the search bar
this is just an amazing gift everyone's
going to enjoy it it's not just steak
omaha steak is a guaranteed fantastic
gift a safe way to share the joy of the
season don't forget when you order that
deluxe griller's assortment you'll also
get four free omaha steaks burgers and a
free digital meat thermometer with my
code shapiro at omahasteaks.com it's a
deal you won't find anywhere else go to
omahastax.com go to that search bar type
in my name
shapiro and up will come the deals they
are just unbelievable go check them out
right now omahastakes.com use shapiro
in the search bar to get the best
available deals okay so over the weekend
president trump headed down to georgia
to campaign for these senate georgia
republicans now i've been saying for
weeks on end anybody who is telling you
that you should boycott a bunch of
republican races
that will decide the fate of the united
states senate and could place
the united states senate at the tender
mercies of if trump does not become
president
kamala harris or in any case at the
hands of chuck schumer
this is like the dumbest thing you could
do and anybody who's telling you to do
that
is a grifter anybody who's telling you
that you need to boycott races because
you're mad about what happened to trump
in georgia or you're mad about the
national election or you suspect voter
fraud so you're going to stay home and
simply hand
send seats to john ossoff who is a
radical
bernie sanders leftist living off his
parents trust fund or raphael warnock a
man so radical that he did
full speeches from the pulpit in his
congregation talking about the wonders
of jeremiah wright putting those people
in the senate as a solution
to your upset about the georgia
presidential race is the dumbest thing
you could do you know who agrees with me
president trump okay it's not me saying
this this is president trump
saying this so president trump went down
to georgia
and he said listen we are here to make
sure that kelly lefler and david perdue
win
it is important that they win i agree
with president trump listen to the guy
here is president trump down in valdosta
georgia over the weekend
we're gathered here tonight to ensure
a very important word ensure
because these are two great great people
that i know so well
and respected by everybody in washington
and beyond
that david perdue and kelly lefler
win the most important congressional
runoff probably in american history i
really believe that i think it's an
american
there's never been a time like this
where
you have two at one time at least you
have two beauties
and you know what you also have two
beauties running against them but beauty
in a different way
okay so president trump is endorsing the
idea that you should go out and vote in
georgia and you should
again no matter how pissed off you are
about georgia and how it's been handling
its business
down there whether that is based or
whether that is baseless okay the bottom
line is you need to vote for the
republicans against the democrats
in georgia i do not for the life of me i
will never understand people who are
saying that they are going to boycott a
georgia senate race and hand the senate
to the democrats
in order to do what punish the democrats
for helping to cheat
if that's your opinion or for what
helping the democrats
rig future elections through through all
sorts of voting proceeds like
what exactly is the logic there there is
no logic this is something trump himself
said he said if you don't vote
socialists win
it was sort of an instinct of mine you
know you're angry because so many votes
were stolen it was taken away
and you say well we're not going to do
it we can't do that we have to actually
do just the opposite
we can't do that we can't do that we
have to do just the opposite
if you don't vote the socialists and the
communists
when they win okay he is correct about
this of course and president trump went
on to describe
some of the democratic senate candidates
in georgia he particularly went after
john ossoff he said this guy is a
left-wing zealot which of course is true
john ossoff is a radical left-wing
zealot
[Music]
who is very proud to be endorsed by
bernie sanders crazy bernie
awesome supports defunding the police
supports the crazy green new deal that's
another beauty
don't forget the green new deal is
really a hundred trillion dollars okay
it's a hundred trillion dollars
okay there is no excuse for not voting
against jonathan
and kelly leflar and uh and raphael
warnock
in georgia how radical are these two
candidates well over the weekend a top
jewish group slammed democrat senate
candidates john ossoff and rafael
warnock in a statement late on saturday
night they campaigned with
representative hank johnson democrat of
georgia who has refused to
who has referred to jews as termites and
accused them of stealing the homes of
palestinians according to ryan sevedra
over at daley wire
the trio reportedly campaigned together
on saturday during a drive-in rally
hosted by county level democrat parties
in their attempts to drive voter
registration
ossoff and warnock's decision to
campaign with johnson who's made
anti-semitic remarks in the past
comes as warnock has faced scrutiny on
the campaign trail for controversial
comments he made a few years ago about
israel
in which he suggested that israel was
willy-nilly killing palestinians for no
reason this drove the republican
jewish coalition to put out a statement
decrying the anti-semitism
of campaigning alongside johnson
yeah the the fact again remains that
these are extraordinarily radical
candidates and you know who pointed that
out last night there were a couple of
debates
last night one was an actual debate one
was not one was the debate between kelly
lefler and raphael warnock kelly lefler
is the sitting united states senator
in georgia she's appointed to fill that
seat rafael warnock is running against
her of course
they ran in this open primary jungle
primary
election in georgia in which warnock won
the plurality of the vote but that's
because lefleur was splitting the vote
with doug holland
on the republican side of the aisle so
leffler went after warnock repeatedly
she said he's a radical liberal the left
was going nuts about this yesterday how
could she
she kept saying over and over he's a
radical liberal well here's an idea
don't run a guy
who was involved in a church praising
fidel castro don't run a guy
who praised jeremiah wright don't run a
guy who decries america as inherently
racist if you don't want to be called a
radical liberal over and over and over
in georgia
that would be your fault that's a you
problem okay you guys created that
and so when kelly lefler points out that
in fact this human is a radical liberal
sorry that one's on you here's kelly
lefler doing that last night
my opponent radical liberal raphael
warnock has called police officers
gangsters
thugs bullies and a threat to our
children when i gave him the chance to
apologize in our first debate he
declined he's also said that you can't
serve god
and the military he's used the bible to
justify these types of attacks
and make other divisive statements what
we need is someone who can bring
together
that can help us get through this
pandemic and rebuild our economy
across this country and right here in
georgia that's what i'm fighting to do
okay and people were very angry at her
you could tell that the left was
believing they'd lost the debate because
they started talking immediately about
whether she had a wire
whichever side is just a general rule of
politics whichever side accuses
the other side of wearing a wire a
debate has lost the debate okay raphael
warnock lost this debate
the only thing that he had to say to
lefleur over and over and over was
you won't say whether trump lost georgia
there's only one problem with this
particular strategy
a plurality of georgians believe trump
didn't lose georgia if you look at
there's a poll that was done over the
weekend
and apparently actually a slight
majority of people
in georgia actually believe that there
was some hanky-panky
in georgia so here is rafael warnock
trying to hit lefleur with an unpopular
proposition in georgia as though this is
going to win him in the senate race
here we are several weeks after the
election and kelly lefler continues to
cast doubt
on an american democratic election
uh it's time to put this behind us and
get focused on the concerns
of ordinary people while she's playing
political games trying to represent
somebody who doesn't live in georgia
jordans are wondering when are they
going to get some covet 19 relief
okay if we're talking about covenant 19
relief which we'll get to in a little
while guess who's holding up cover 19
relief
the democrats the democrats in it has
nothing to do with trump it has nothing
to do with the election or voter fraud
the people who are holding up the covert
relief are democrats so this is a weak t
response and he had no responses to
anything lefler said about him
last night so if anybody watched that
debate in georgia
and then decides you're going to sit it
out after lefleur correctly points out
how radical
warnock is you're making a grave error
you wanna put that dude in the senate
gonna put that bad dude in the senate
bad bad idea meanwhile john ossoff did a
debate with david perdue's podium so
david perdue was like you know what i'm
not debating this guy because every time
i
do a debate with this guy all he does is
slander me so forget it so he did a
debate last night
in which he just talked to an open
podium
and it turns out that john ostoff can't
even win a debate against an open podium
i mean he lost a race against karen
handel for congress very hotly contested
race in georgia
just a couple of years back and now he
is back debating empty podiums
so here he was and this was supposed to
be a great winning moment for him yeah
not so much
well it's a a strange situation
to be asking a question of
a sitting united states senator who is
not here to debate
as he asks for the votes of the people
to be reelected
senator perdue i suppose doesn't feel
that he can handle himself
in debate or perhaps is concerned that
he may incriminate himself
in debate both of which in my opinion
are disqualifying
okay um that guy yeah hmm okay
good good times when you can't win when
they when the opposite podium is
actually more interesting than you are
in a debate like at least at least when
clint eastwood did the empty chair thing
it was actually kind of funny
and interesting and creative this guy
lost a debate to an empty podium
which is really really difficult to do
john ossoff okay in just a second we're
gonna get to the continuing controversy
over the election because president
trump didn't just talk about why you
should vote republican
in georgia in the senate elections he
also talked about his own election and
the prospect
for his uh for a second term or a joe
biden first term we'll get to that in
just
one second first let us talk about your
sleep quality so i'll be honest with you
last night was not a great night of
sleep for me i had a baby who woke up
several times
in the middle of the night and then also
my wife decided it would be a smart idea
to
leave open the door to our room and then
we sort of forgot about that because
it's behind the curtains and then it was
raining last night so that was not a
great idea but
in the moment when my room was not being
flooded and my baby was not screaming at
me
i really needed my sleep and this is why
i needed my helix sleep mattress helix
sleep it's got a quiz
just takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences so the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you are getting
a mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome
getting unboxing videos from so many of
you who also found the helix sleep
mattress of
your dreams right now just go to
helixsleep.com take their two minute
sleep quiz
you too will be sleeping on a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep
of your life 10-year warranty you have
to try it out for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you absolutely will
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners that is an excellent
excellent deal
right now check them out remember
helixlek.com they're offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders and two
free pillows
for our listeners go check them out
right now helixsleep.com
ben okay so president trump in georgia
continued to maintain that democrats
rigged the election so here's president
trump
in valdosta now notice members of the
media were very upset that trump was
propagating two messages at the same
time
one is that he got jobs in georgia the
other is that republicans
should in fact go out and vote for
republican senate candidates
in georgia now you can't hold those two
thoughts in your mind at the exact same
time
but see for the left what they want is
for trump to completely ignore the
senate races what they would like
this is the reason why they were
celebrating from talking about voter
fraud they were saying this is great
trump should he's gonna go down to
georgia he's gonna talk voter fraud and
he's gonna discourage people from voting
but that's not what trump did
he went down there he says listen i got
jobs i feel like we're going to move
forward with the process
but i'd feel like i got cheated and also
you should go out and vote for the
senate candidate
and democrats were unduly angry at this
because of course
they were hoping that trump would go
down there and basically do exactly what
lynn
would and uh and sydney powell have been
doing and tell people not to vote for
the senate candidates because democrats
all they care about is that republicans
lose power they don't care how it
happens they just care that republicans
lose power anyway here was trump talking
about the possibility of a voter
regularity in florida in georgia
you must go vote and vote early starting
december 14th you have to do it they
cheated and they rigged our presidential
election
but we will still win it we will still
win it
we'll still win it and they're going to
try and rig this election too
okay so again that's actually not a
horrible get out the vote message
which is they're going to try to rig the
election so get out and vote really
early and make sure that they can't do
what the mail ends what i'm saying they
did
with the mail-ins and trump pushing that
message
is actually not a bad message now i'm
getting a lot of mail from people who
are asking like why do so many
republicans believe
that this election was rigged why do so
many republicans seem to be clinging to
the idea
that trump was cheated in this election
well i mean listen there are some
puzzling questions about the election
like the fact that trump seemed to
underperform the rest of the republican
ticket i think there are plausible
answers as to why that happened if
indeed it turns out that voter
irregularity and voter fraud are not
responsible
for the current results there are people
saying okay he got he got kind of
he he overperformed on minorities he
underperformed in the suburbs but why
didn't that amount to a trump victory so
why are so many
uh right why are so many republicans
buying into trump's narrative that this
whole thing was voter irregularity
the answer is this okay when people have
been lied to for years and years and
years and years then the same people who
lied to them for years and years and
years turn around and say another thing
people are immediately going to assume
it's a lie it's really that simple
if you spent four years claiming that
donald trump was not the legitimate
president in 2016
because he was manipulating the system
with the russians
nobody is going to believe you when you
say that he was booted from office
in a fully legitimate election you
literally could not
acknowledge that it was a legitimate
election in 2016 and now here you are in
2020 saying well suddenly it's a
legitimate election again nobody's gonna
believe you
when you blow out your own credibility
it makes it very difficult for anybody
to trust you
on issues like is this current election
legit was there any voter fraud was
there any voter irregularity it makes it
very difficult for anybody on the right
to believe anybody in the media
who less than three months ago was
claiming that donald trump was going to
rig the election through getting rid of
mail mailboxes right that donald trump
was going to
engage in voter suppression and then
they flip and suddenly it's the cleanest
election in the world
no one is going to believe that now it
may be that the election
was not rigged it may be the election
was clean or it may be that two things
could be true at once the election was
not decided by voter fraud and voter
irregularity but the processes by which
the election happened
did tend toward democrats and they are
not the way we should run elections in
the future
and the media helped rig this election
via it's its
refusal to focus on actual stories that
damage joe biden
and lying narratives over and over and
over again ranging from trump is
responsible for kovid to trump as a
white supremacist
to trump is a russian plan right all of
those things can be true at once
but here's one thing that is certainly
true if you look at a list of
institutions americans trust right now
media is at the very very bottom of that
list and so members of the media keep
shouting into the wind it was a clean
election and then they wonder why people
don't believe them the answer is because
you don't have any credibility
one of the reasons you have no
credibility is because you are willing
to go along with any democratic
narrative you possibly can
so over the weekend john brennan right
who's a democrat
right he was in the he was the head of
the cia under
barack obama he was on with chris
wallace
and he was saying that there was no
spying on the trump campaign
okay now john brennan is also one of the
people who's out there saying today
that it was a super clean election okay
why would i believe john brennan the man
actually lied to the senate
he lied to congress he said that he had
not been spying on the senate that was
not true
and now he's saying there's no spying on
the trump campaign and then the same
sentence he's saying it was a clean
election
see the source matters when it comes to
credibility now this is not an argument
again
as to whether the election was clean or
whether the election was dirty
it is an argument that when all of the
main sources who declare that they are
telling you the truth have been lying to
you for years it makes it very very
difficult for people to buy into that
here is john brennan saying an untrue
thing as we have said previously the
steele dossier was not used in any way
to undergird the judgments that came out
of the intelligence community assessment
about the russian actions in the 2016
election
and so the 20 the steele dossier was
something that i never
you know looked at from the standpoint
of credibility
because it wasn't something that the cia
had acquired
and so i think you know people point to
the steele dossier as this you know
reason why the whole thing was a hoax no
there was so much other evidence and
intelligence to support those judgments
okay there there wasn't a lot of other
evidence there wasn't a lot of other
judgment and
he also maintained that there was no
spying period on the trump campaign
which of course is just not true and
there are members of the trump campaign
like carter page and members of the
intel community who
have now been informed as to the evils
of the fisa warrant taken out against
carter page have fully admitted that the
fisa awards never should have been taken
out against carter page here's brennan
just denying there was any spying on the
trump campaign at all which of course is
not correct
looking back at 2016 were there some
mistakes made in terms of the fisa
applications those types of things
yes apparently they were but that
doesn't mean that there was criminal
intent
and there was no spying on donald
trump's campaign
and it's very clear from robert
mueller's investigation that there were
a lot of activities that
i think were very unprincipled unethical
and
it'll be up to individuals in the future
to determine whether or not there was
any criminal activity
that took place during that time i i
love to hear about unprincipled
unethical criminal activity from a guy
who openly lied to the united states
senate was forced to back off of it
he's definitely a credible source we
should believe him probably he seems
credible
we'll get to more on the credibility of
members of the media and the claims that
are being made about voter fraud and
voter regularity in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that the holidays are here
and right now most people have a balance
on their credit card with a higher
interest rate than they would prefer
if you've got a balance on that credit
card and you've waited more than like a
month to pay it
the interest rates really start racking
up this is how you end up in a cycle
of debt and it's a real problem i've
seen people like bankrupt themselves
just by taking out
a credit card they start spending on the
credit card before they know it they are
paying 20
interest rates it's crazy okay this is
why you need to roll your high interest
credit card payments into
one payment at a lower fixed rate light
streams credit card consolidation loans
have rates as low as 5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
you can get a loan from 5 000 to 100 000
plus there are absolutely no fees no
application fees no no origination fees
no transaction fees and no prepayment
penalties you can even get your money as
soon as the day you apply
lightstream believes people with good
credit deserve a better loan experience
that's exactly what they deliver
people love lightstream one customer
says i heard about lightstream on this
podcast i was able to look on the
website get clear information
the application process was quick and
easy and it will be for you as well
my listeners can save even more with an
additional interest rate discount the
only way to get this discount is to go
to lightstream.com
shapiro l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m
dot com shapiro subject to credit
approval rates range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include 0.50
autopay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply
offers are subject to change with that
notice visit lightstream.com shapiro
for more information okay so all of this
has led to a sort of radical skepticism
about anybody
see here here's one of the problems
skepticism about john brennan totally
justified skepticism about members of
the media
who five minutes ago were declaring this
election was going to be dirty and
rigged for trump
now declaring that because they think
biden won the election everything was
clean as the driven snow i understand
distrust of those people
the shift to anybody who now does not go
along
with the with the trump loss because of
voter fraud and voter irregularity
narrative
that shift is too much okay so for
example maria bartoromo
she she was asking john ratcliff who's
the director of national intelligence
intelligence who got to bill barr
nobody got to bilbar the attorney
general bill barr has been an excellent
attorney general
he's done a lot of the things that trump
supporters would want also he happens to
be a person who is abided by the law
bill barr has been an excellent
straightforward clear and convincing
attorney general
but here's maria bartoromo suggesting
that somebody got to bill barr okay once
again to the point where you're
suggesting bill barr was bribed in order
to go along with this
that's not correct okay billboard
himself put out a statement last week
saying the media had taken his comments
about voter fraud too far he had said i
have seen
no systemic evidence of voter fraud he
did not say we've been doing massive
investigations into systemic evidence of
voter fraud
he says any any evidence that's brought
to light we are going to investigate
but at no point did he say that absence
of evidence equals evidence of absence
right he
like just because i haven't seen voter
fraud doesn't mean voter fraud didn't
occur
right but here's maria bartoroma going
too far again if you've gone to the
point where
everybody on the right side of the aisle
who is skeptical about
voter fraud allegations in the absence
of convincing evidence
is now bought off or something that's
too far that's
again skepticism warranted every
i was the first person i think to say
every legal vote needs to be counted and
every illegal vote needs not to be
counted
right this has now become the talking
point on the right i was the first
person to put it out there
okay that is totally worthwhile and it
is totally true
and just because a media member who's
been non-credible from the start begins
to
suggest over and over and over that the
election is over does not necessarily
mean the election is over the election
is over
when the electoral college votes on
december 14th end of story right states
certifying their votes means that those
states have now certified their votes
and there's not much that can be done
about that absent a court order okay but
for for people to start you know going
after bill barr
that is a bridge too far here's maria by
roma going a bridge too far
speaking of threats and uh bullying
who who got to bill barr i've got to ask
you your thoughts on where we are here
with a.g bill barr and john durham
it seems like it's an about face we were
expecting
a real investigation into what took
place in why crossfire hurricane the
investigation into donald trump
uh still has no accountability
okay so again nobody got to bill barr
this idea that somebody got to build bar
is absurd and ridiculous and people
should not be implying that sort of
stuff okay billboard has been a very
good a.g
meanwhile rudy giuliani he came out and
said somebody in washington directed
voter fraud but i don't know who okay
these kind of allegations are not
particularly helpful
again he's the president's lawyer bring
the evidence i want the same thing that
rudy giuliani wants that most of you
want
right i would like to see trump remain
in office i would love that
it would be great okay what i would also
like is for a legal process to take
place where rudy giuliani brings the
evidence that he's been suggesting over
and over he is going to bring
and i don't mean that he brings
affidavits that are unbacked by other
supporting evidence anybody can file an
affidavit especially one that is not
filed in court i mean if you want to
change the outcome of the election
you're going to need to prove your case
in court end of story i didn't create
the process
you didn't create the process the
process is the process if you want the
election outcomes to change that is the
way it's going to change
it does not help when rudy just goes on
tv and then says things like some vague
unspecified power in washington dc
fix the election i don't even know what
that means that's not evidenced so how
am i supposed to judge whether it's true
or not
each one of them has in one degree or
another
almost the same pattern of activity one
a little bit more than others
this was a pattern that was set by
somebody in washington
because everybody else carried it out
exactly in the same way
and they did it in the crooked cities
they didn't do it everywhere i mean i
don't know
who was in charge of it all i can tell
you is it looks like a very well planned
very well executed situation okay again
those sorts of vague allegations are not
going to be particularly useful again if
you want a result
if you just want to about the
election they're useful if you want an
actual result you're going to have to do
the hard work of pinning all this stuff
down i know that's a high burden i
understand it's a high burden
that doesn't mean that things are going
to change absent meeting the burden
that's just the way it is okay like i
don't mean to be the bearer of bad
tidings here
but i would like trump like you i would
like trump
to remain president of the united states
if you want him to remain president of
the united states than putting out
speculation
about how trump definitely could not
have lost or putting out statistical
anomalies that's not gonna be enough
you're gonna have to actually prove it
again i'm talking about the practical
on the ground messaging you're gonna
have to actually show it
in court if you want the results to
change otherwise i mean i suppose that
we can we can
move along and just believe that
everybody's done their job but if the
job's gonna get done somebody's gonna
have to do it and that person presumably
is gonna have to be trump's legal team
okay in just one second we're gonna get
to joe biden and his awful plans we'll
get to that in just one second then
we'll get to covet and everything else
that's been happening over the weekend
because there's a lot
first it's doorbell season the busiest
time of year at your front door that is
definitely true at my house right now
there's a ton of activity at my front
door got lots of packages arriving for
hanukkah
plus i'm mailing lots of packages okay
there's just a lot happening at the
front door
and this is why you need a ring okay
ring will help you keep an eye on
everything happening at your house
outside inside
it's just fantastic i have three kids
under the age of seven there are three
of them
there's one of me i cannot keep an eye
on all three of them but you know who
can
ring can if somebody stops by or
something is going on ring will let you
know you can see and speak to whoever is
there from anywhere
this holiday season is not just the best
time to have ring but the best time to
give it as well
ring makes the perfect holiday gift this
holiday season give somebody the gift
of peace of mind ring has security
products for every corner of your home
inside now best of all
you can see it all in the ring app ring
has everything you need to keep an eye
on your home this holiday season and
throughout the year see and speak to
whoever is at your door from anywhere
with video doorbells for a limited time
go to ring.com ben for special holiday
offers again that is ring.com for those
special holiday offers ring.com
ben to make sure that your home is
protected and the way you want it to be
protected
ring can make that happen for you help
protect that whole home with ring alarm
get the easy to install indoor and
outdoor cams make sure that it happens
ring.com
to keep your home more safe and secure
okay
meanwhile quick note here so there's a
story that came out from at michigan
a couple of dozen protesters according
to the detroit free press a couple of
dozen protesters gathered in front of
michigan secretary of state jocelyn
benson's home saturday night
shouting through megaphones against the
certification of the election demanding
a forensic audit
a portion of the demonstration was
broadcast live on facebook around 9 30
p.m
the protesters are seen walking up to
benson's detroit home
some wearing paraphernalia from the
trump campaign carrying american flags
jean viv peters who posted a live video
said we are over here in the freaking
dead of nightmare we are letting her
know
we're not taking this bs election we're
not standing down we're not giving up
you're not going to take this election
from a man who earned it completely 100
by a freaking landslide
this isn't over benson said the
protesters gathered in front of her home
as she and her four-year-old son were
finishing putting up christmas
decorations
okay so just basic rule of thumb here
no matter how pissed off you are about
the election how about this stay away
from people's houses
okay still like we're gonna have to
share this country after this is all
over i said this to the left and i'll
say this to everybody
stay away from other people's houses it
was bad when the left descended on
carlson's house it is bad when
restaurants throw sarah huckabee sanders
out and it is bad when you descend on
somebody's home
where they are with their children
because you don't like something that is
happening in politics
do not do it it is a bad thing and
meanwhile speaking
of things that are bad happening in
american politics so joe biden has been
promoted as this magical sort of
moderate who's going to bring the
country together which of course is a
joke
he's not a moderate nor is he a magical
magical man joe biden says we're going
to need to take the vitriol out of
politics
here with biden over the weekend we've
got to take the vitriol
out of politics i know there's a lot of
people on both sides
who want to continue to go after and
punish the opposition
i get that i get the fact that an awful
lot of americans
are disappointed i was elected president
fortunately there's seven million more
that were happy than disappointed but
i get that and there's a lot of
democrats who are
angry and want to strike back
republicans
but i've said from the beginning i've i
think i've
conducted myself this way throughout my
career
i learned that early lesson it's always
appropriate to question other man or
woman's judgment but never their motive
okay yeah i'm sure that he literally
said that he wanted to
put mitt romney want to put black people
back in chains and joe biden went after
he he created borking and then bragged
about it you know joe biden is not a
unifying figure and how do you know he's
not a unifying figure
because he has now picked xavier becerra
to lead the department of health and
human services should he be inaugurated
president in january
for those who don't know xavier bacera
the man is a radical leftist he's a
radical leftist he's been attorney
general
of the state of california where i was a
resident until very very recently
and he is just terrible he's absolutely
terrible so not only has he spent his
career trying to protect
obamacare but also he has gone after
pro-lifers in extraordinary
ways susan b anthony let's put out a
statement they said far from uniting the
country biden has proven yet again he's
an extremist on abortion this is going
to
sba list president marjorie dannenfelser
becerra is aggressively pro-abortion a
foe of free speech
as attorney general of california he
continued what his predecessor kamala
harris started by persecuting citizen
journalists who exposed planned
parenthood's role in baby parts
trafficking
not only that he went all the way to the
supreme court to try to force
california's pro-life pregnancy centers
to advertise and refer for abortion
a policy the court rejected is
unconstitutional in congress even voted
in favor of partial birth abortion
this pick underscores the importance of
winning in georgia to prevent
pro-abortion forces from taking control
of the united states senate so basera
what's being referred to there is a case
in which becerra went directly after
david deladen so david delaine was a
pro-life activist
and beccero announced charges against
deladen and somebody else working with
him a woman named sandra merritt
saying the state would not tolerate the
criminal recording of confidential
conversations what were
those confidential conversations delayed
did secret recording
for reporting purposes of planned
parenthood employees
talking about selling fetal tissue
right and so what did xavier becara do
in the state of california did he turn
on planned parenthood did he investigate
planned parenthood of course not
of course not instead the state of
california led by xavier becerra went
after delayeden
so deladen claimed the video showed
footage of planned parenthood selling at
the tissue
planned parenthood said the footage was
misleadingly edited of course now they
were talking pretty openly about the
cost
of particular pieces of fetal tissue
that they were selling
planned parenthood if they did talk
about that pretty openly
in the tape and then they claimed that
it was deceivingly edited and all of
this
so becerra didn't go after planned
parenthood of course instead he
initiated prosecutions
against deladen and merit so
this is who joe biden has decided should
lead up hhs
which is just ridiculous on its face and
one of the reasons that biden selected
him is because of course
joe biden needs more latinos in the
cabinet because joe biden has already
vowed that he's going to select people
based on this color of their skin
rather than the content of their
character there was worry that he was
actually going to make him attorney
general so frankly
i'm i'm a little bit relieved that he's
that he's talking about becerra for hhs
as opposed to
becerra over at ag i can't even imagine
he's going to put over at
aj i mean that's just a disaster area
the hhs position is the third role at
the helm of the biden team's pandemic
response to be filled in the past few
days
biden is looking to jeff zens the
co-chair of the transition as the white
house corona virus coordinator
he led the white house national economic
council under barack obama
and of course he is looking at vivek
murthy co-chair of the administration's
code advisory board uh as the
surgeon general he's also giving a
special slot to uh anthony fauci quick
note on anthony fauci by the way
so i was just uh at the local
grocery store the other day and they had
some of these magazines out
and they're looking at me glowing from
the cover of like an in touch magazine
was anthony fauci
and i thought to myself isn't that guy
like just the kovid relief
guy is isn't that guy like the kovid guy
like why is it
that he is on the cover of intouch
magazine why is he being giving
glossy treatment by the entire press
for being an advisor with regard to a
coronavirus pandemic
and the answer of course is because he
was perceived as anti-trump he's seen as
a critic of trump and therefore he gets
the rosie treatment debra burks never
got that treatment because deborah burks
as much as she disagreed with trump
really kept it under wraps and
understood she had a job to do within
the framework of an administration
but my respect for anthony fauci drops
fairly radically
once you start posing for magazine
covers like in touch
with your stethoscope around your neck
at that point you're just doing a little
bit of self-promotion
okay speaking of self-promotion coveted
policy continues to be extraordinarily
bad across the country
so california has now locked down tens
of millions of citizens according to cnn
southern california and san joaquin
valley residents will be under a
stay-at-home order
after the icu capacity in the two
regions fell below 15
triggering a mandate issued by the
governor earlier this week that aims to
bring down the soaring number of coveted
hospitalizations now to be fair there is
flex capacity at some of these hospitals
a lot of these hospitals always run at
near capacity in terms of the icus
because you're always doing surgeries
hospitals that run at 50 capacity are
not called hospitals they are now called
boarded up
old hospitals that don't exist anymore
because the way the system works is that
the beds have to be filled in order for
people to get paid
so instead what we're talking about is
telling people to stay home if they have
optional surgeries
so we can fill those icu beds with
people who have covid
that does not mean that we have not seen
a surge we have indeed seen a surge it
does mean that all of the talk
especially in major areas with with
pretty significant medical resources
like los angeles
they're talking about telling people to
stay home they're not talking about la
being completely overwhelmed
by coveted cases the
california order went into effect last
night at midnight
for 27 million people it includes l.a
and san diego
that follows a proactive order issued by
six san francisco bay area jurisdictions
on friday for it's almost 6 million
residents
it also it also went into effect on
sunday again
newsom on thursday announced any region
that fell below the 15
icu capacity threshold would be placed
under state at home orders
southern california reported that its
icu available availability fell to 12.5
on saturday in san joaquin it was 8.6
california has been surging now quick
note california never stopped its
lockdown so for all the talk about
harsher lockdowns and stay at home
owners
california never went back to business
as usual there was no point really at
which the restaurants opened indoors
there was no point in which people
started treating normal everyday
activities as normal everyday activities
most of the businesses in la were still
boarded up and closed down
people were not going into their regular
jobs this has been true since march
so the basic idea the government was
going to be able to enforce quarantine
and this was going to magically quash
everything
there's not a lot of evidence that that
is the case schools that are already
open for in-person learning can remain
open along with critical infrastructure
businesses
retail businesses can stay open but only
at 20 capacity restaurants are limited
to takeout
and delivery alone and the order is in
effect for at least three weeks
now here is one of the problems these
orders scientifically do not make a
whole hell of a lot of sense
and so for example you're not allowed to
do outdoor dining
anymore in like l.a county they've
decided you're not the evidence on
outdoor dining there is none that
outdoor dining is spreading this thing
there's evidence that indoor dining is
spreading this thing there's no evidence
that outdoor dining
is spreading this thing nonetheless they
shut down the outdoor dining
in l.a county however under emergency
mandates the film industry is still
allowed
to have food outdoors under tents
because the film industry has been
deemed essential
by the state of california so these
asshat hypocrites
they're saying that you can't open your
restaurant outdoors but so long as
you're working for gavin newsom's
favorite industry all of his friends in
hollywood
all the glitterati well then you can eat
at a food tent directly
off-site now you can definitely make
sure that all of the grips
can have their food catered by some sort
of food truck outside of a
in a food tent which last i checked it's
called outdoor dining
in fact here is one california
restaurant owner protesting this over
the weekend
i'm losing everything everything i own
is being taken away from me
and they set up a movie company right
next
to my outdoor patio which is right over
here
and people wonder why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive my
staff cannot survive
okay she's a hundred percent right and
there she is you can't see the video
pointing at a tent that is set up with
picnic tables so that this film crew can
make sure that they eat outside
so only if you're a member of the
special favored industry do you actually
get to eat outdoors
everybody else if you're in a restaurant
you are absolutely screwed
you're done but if you work for one of
eric garcetti's favorite industries in
los angeles or if you work one of gavin
newsom's favorite industries in
california
well then you are totally fine because
so much of this is political
so much of this is about catering to a
particular voter base
so much of this is about keeping
industries that you like open and
closing industries that you don't
particularly like
by the way eric garcetti's response to
this he responded directly to this lady
and erica garcetti suggested that his
heart goes out to her but we have to
stop the virus he said
my heart goes out to miss marsden and
the workers of the pineapple hill saloon
who have to comply with state and county
public health restrictions that close
outdoor dining
no one likes these restrictions but i do
support them as our hospital icu beds
filled to capacity and cases
have increased by 500 percent we must
stop this virus before it kills
thousands of more angelenos
but um how about that tent that's right
there with the outdoor dining no
comments on that
from eric garcetti all of which has led
the sheriff of one california county to
say i'm not gonna enforce these rules
if you think that i'm gonna drive up to
a business that is serving outdoor
dining and shut them down you got
another thing coming here's the
california sheriff saying this yesterday
these closures and stay-at-home orders
are flat-out ridiculous
the metrics used for closures are
unbelievably faulty
and are not representative of true
numbers and are disastrous for riverside
county
while the governor's office and the
state has threatened action against
violators
the riverside county sheriff's
department will not be blackmailed
bullied or used as muscle against
riverside county residents
in the enforcement of the governor's
orders that is exactly right good for
that guy
good for that guy in just a second we're
going to bring you proof
at full scale lockdowns aren't all
they're cracked up to be again i'm not
saying you can't restrict indoor dining
to a particular capacity
if you are in a hard-hit area i'm not
saying that you shouldn't wear a mask
when you're close to other people you
should wear a mask when you're close to
other people
i'm saying the orders in places like l.a
county make no sense and they are
politically driven because they make no
sense and they are politically driven
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first
let us talk about something great that
you can do for your friends and family
this holiday season i'm talking about
taking all those old memories out in the
garage
and preserving them forever i got them
on vhs tapes you got them on film reels
you have them on old
photos negatives and they're just
sitting out there doing nothing instead
why not have those preserved
in digital format so they live forever
you can access them whenever you want
and god forbid there's an emergency
instead of having to schlep
boxes into a truck or something you just
grab your thumb drive and you are good
to go this is what legacy box does their
service could not be simpler
you can use their kit to safely send the
moments you want preserved their team
will create a digital archive by hand
and then you receive your new copy
stored on the cloud thumb drive or dvd
along with all the original media you
sent them with their tracking system
you can monitor every step of the
process so you always know your
originals are being taken care of
over the past 10 years legacy box has
helped close to 1 million families
restore and protect their most cherished
memories
right now they're offering 60 off so you
can have everything preserved at once
for a fraction of the regular price
once you have these digital versions you
can relax knowing they will be secure
for generations i know legacy box is
great i know that it works because i did
it for my parents they are just
overjoyed they can suddenly access
footage of their own grandparents they
haven't seen for probably 40 years this
is the best deal of the year go to
legacybox.com
shapiro right now to take advantage of
this limited time offer and get 60
percent off
the exclusive offer will not last long
order their kit now send it in whenever
you're ready it's a sales remember go to
legacybox.com slash approval save 60
wow supplies last i know the dudes who
run the company fantastic fantastic
company
check them out right now legacybox.com
shapiro save 60
wow supplies last okay more on covet
policy
and democrats continuing to hold up
covered relief in the middle of a
pandemic
we'll get to that in just one second
first if you're not already a daily
guard member now is the time
to join we've got incredible stuff right
around the corner last friday december
4th
kicked off the michael moles show going
five days a week adding more content for
our members to enjoy or not enjoy
because it's the michael noel show also
we're adding the entire prageru catalog
to dailywire.com by the end of the year
we've already uploaded
all of prageru's five minute videos the
candas owens show from prageru and
michael knowles book club the rest of
the library is being added as we speak
also early next year
candace is joining the daily wire here
in nashville she'll be launching a brand
new daily wire show in front of a live
studio audience
we're also launching our first feature
film under daily wires upcoming
entertainment channel i could not be
more pumped about that we're going to
compete
with hollywood in the r rated film
category we're gonna do edgy stuff we're
gonna do interesting stuff and we're
gonna bring you a competitor to the
garbage that hollywood is spewing out
each and every day
and then asking you to buy we are also
building a new investigative journalism
team to replace the legacy media cartels
remember all those media members i told
you you couldn't trust we're going to
build an investigative journalist you
can trust so
go outside the narrative come on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe we're loud we're opinionated
and we are having
a good time now you've seen this before
right this left is tears tumblr
you've seen this before well have you
ever taken a sip
from this this baby right here oh yeah
it's the new
improved leftist tears check this out
this is magnificent
my god this thing could survive a
nuclear war it's beautiful
it shines with joy and it has a logo of
a tier on the back
because it's for leftist ears of course
keep the leftist hears hot or cold
in a new stainless steel design with a
custom
daily wire lid oh yeah very very snazzy
so
join daily wearer upgrade your
membership to get this magical
apparatus also makes julienne fries
you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so all these lockdown orders
they're supposedly going to protect you
right
well griff witt reporting for the
washington post quote the governor had
been sounding the alarm for more than a
month
by mid-november it was clear to michelle
lujan grisham
she would need to take extreme measures
to head off the most serious emergency
new mexico has ever faced
with covet 19 cases rising exponentially
and hospital beds dwindling
she dragged her state back to the
darkest days of spring when restaurant
dining was banned non-essential
businesses were closed
residents were ordered to stay inside
unless absolutely necessary
she said quote new mexico has crushed
this virus before twice we're going to
do it again
three weeks later victory remains a
distant prospect instead luhan grisham a
democrat is on the verge of
acknowledging just how grim conditions
have become
she will she said in an interview soon
allow hospitals to move to crisis
standards
a move that frees them to ration care
depending on a patient's likelihood
of surviving given the severe strain on
medical systems statewide and the lack
of available icu beds as coveted
hospitalizations at near 1000 statewide
according to jason mitchell the chief
medical officer at presbyterian
healthcare services he said there was
likely no other choice he said we're
headed there very quickly there's no
more room
at the inn new mexico has consistently
won praise among public health experts
for its aggressive approach to combating
the virus lujan grisham issued a
stay-at-home order in march when there
were fewer than 100 cases statewide
she's gone as far as locking down entire
cities to stem the spread
a study by oxford university found the
state's approach was among most
restrictive and also the most successful
with new mexico dodging the spring and
summer surges that afflicted so many
other states
both pandemic fatigue growing and
political resistance building new mexico
has not escaped the outbreak raging
nationwide this fall
even though there's evidence the
governor's november shutdown orders are
helping reduce case numbers experts say
there's only so much they can do with a
virus that zealously exploits
any weakness okay so here's the bottom
line unless you lock people in bubbles
in their homes then this thing is going
to move
through the community because that has
been true literally the entire time
locking down is not the answer treating
people as rational human beings is the
answer
and one of the bigger problems here is
again this goes right back to the
argument we were making at the beginning
about voter fraud okay when you have
sources who make themselves
untrustworthy and then they ask you to
do a thing
even if the thing happens to be correct
or factual you are not going to trust
the sources
when you had your medical source is
telling you first of all you should go
out and party it up in february because
the wuhan virus wasn't going to hurt you
which is literally what we had democrats
and republicans by the way doing then
people are not going to pay attention to
you
and then when you say don't wear a mask
masks are useless as anthony fauci said
in early march
people are not going to pay attention to
you later when you're like you need to
wear a mask everywhere and then when you
say
we need to lock this thing down for 15
days and then we'll be good
and then you lock everybody down for the
rest of their lives people aren't going
to listen and when you say here's a lock
down order but it's not going to apply
to me i'm going to go out to a
restaurant people are not going to
listen to you
when you blow out your own credibility
instead of saying to people listen here
are the facts the fact is
this thing striated by age right if
you're very young if you're a kid it
ain't gonna hurt you
if you're under the age of 20 the
likelihood that you're going to be dead
from this disease is lower than the
likelihood you'll die of the flu
if you are older than that and you don't
have a significant pre-existing
condition
there's a 99.5 chance that you're going
to be fine
right if you these are the actual stats
by the way
by the way that 99.5 stat statistic that
is true for the entire population
overall including people with
pre-existing conditions
because right now the best information
we have is that this thing has about a
0.05 death rate
overall for the population right that
this thing is is
not uh sorry 8.5 death rate for the
entire population
okay so so that means that 995 out of
every 1000 human beings who get this
including people who are elderly
including people with pre-existing
conditions will live
so instead of talking to people as
though they are reasonable
and telling them what they can do that
is reasonable instead you said these
outside standards i get it i do
i understand that if you want to protect
people you think that you're going to
set what in judaism you call a fence
around the law
the problem is that when you set fences
that nobody's going to abide by they
breach the fence and then they proceed
to run roughshod
over the rest of the recommendations it
also happens to be true that when you
propagate misinformation routinely
that you can't swivel on a diamond how
people just hope people will trust you
so here's an example
here's a great example of people
propagating information that just is not
true
and then reversing themselves
willy-nilly so for months we heard that
if you open schools it was a disaster
mostly we heard that from a media that
was convinced that trump had to be wrong
about everything
because trump was out there saying you
need to open the schools this is silly
it's bad it's hurting kids
and teachers unions were saying no no we
need to keep the schools closed
and for months the media were like you
know what trump's the worst man let's
keep those schools closed we don't know
how dangerous it's going to be it could
kill little kids we don't know doesn't
matter the stats show that little kids
are not dying of this
it still could kill little kids right
it's deeply deeply dangerous
and then people take that to heart and
this leads to footage like this footage
this is from oregon of a teacher
stopping an anti-lockdown protester to
scream and shout like a crazy person
because she is very upset that people
are protesting against lockdowns
and she's talking about how her parents
family her kids families are dying of
covid
and how she's at risk here's a little
bit of that footage
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
okay that's sort of hysteria i mean that
is hysteria there's no other way to put
it that sort of hysteria is utterly
unjustified
but it's been pushed by t-shirts unions
and by the media
the chicago's teachers union over the
weekend tweeted out it's got 20 000
28 000 members they tweeted out quote
the push to reopen schools is rooted in
sexism
racism and misogyny sexism racism and
misogyny
right this has been the narrative of the
left it's been the narrative of the
media so
why exactly would we trust the media
when it comes to
either shutting down or reopening
because here is now the
editorial board of the washington post
coming along in december right in the
middle of the worst outbreak that we've
seen thus far
an editorial board that was like ah you
know we're not sure about this whole
school thing we're not you know
here is the editorial board of the
washington post what could have changed
in the last month could there be an
election or something because here's the
new headline
students have already lost too much time
they need to be back in classrooms
oh weird because those of us were saying
this months ago were castigated and are
still being castigated by the teachers
unions as people who don't care about
the lives of teachers who are bad
uncaring unfeeling evil now here's the
washington post
that was propagating a lot of this panic
porn for months on end
and they're like you know what it's time
for kids to go back to school yeah no
bleep sherlock
but you think i'm gonna trust you on
that rongo
not going to trust you on that i'm going
to trust people who've been fairly
consistent throughout this whole thing
looking for reasonable measures but here
comes the washington post
and why look at that they think joe
biden was elected president and now
they've reversed themselves on schooling
since the outbreak of the covenant 19
pandemic teachers principals
administrators and parents
across the u.s have worked mightily to
help students keep learning
students developed new curricula provide
schools developed new curricula
provided children with portable
computers labor to give some semblance
of structure to remote learning
even with these efforts remote learning
has failed to provide anything
approaching the quality of education
that can be delivered by a teacher
in a classroom it's clear that there are
pernicious effects of keeping children
out of schools we recently asked a top
official in a washington area
jurisdiction who insisted on anonymity
why there wasn't more of a push to
figure out ways to return children to
the classroom
the answer was there was no political
pressure parents of means can give their
kids the help and resources they need or
switch them to a private school
parents of minority or disadvantaged
students with the most to lose have the
least clouds
well maybe it's because you in the media
didn't do your damn jobs on the cove
pandemic all the way from the beginning
and you're still not doing your job
you're still not doing your job okay
you continue to purvey the panic porn
that suggests that everybody is equally
likely to die of this virus
you keep suggesting over and over that
full-scale lockdowns that are completely
hypocritical in their actual application
are totally fine
when's the last time by the way you saw
a business owner who'd been completely
destroyed on cnn or msnbc you only see
it on fox news you only hear about that
from my show or shows like it you won't
hear it in the media but this is the
media that asks you to trust them
this is the same media that's blaming
trump for a lack of covert relief well
now nancy pelosi is completely flipped
on coveted relief and nobody in the
media will even notice it so nancy
pelosi who has held up a coveted relief
package
for months on end for no apparent
political reason other than to get
beyond the election
because she thought it would hurt trump
now she says we're not leaving
washington dc without the relief
and the media like oh look at that nancy
pelosi leader it's incredible
here's nancy pelosi being a giant
hypocrite
we have to have an omnibus and we're
hoping that that will accelerate the
discussions on the omnibus
we are going to keep government open you
know we're not going to have a
continuing resolution
but we need to take the time to do that
and then as i said we saw a framework
they're putting uh now they have to turn
it into text
and then and so we'll take the time we
need and we must get it done and we must
get it done
by uh this before we leave we cannot
leave without it
i mean and the media just went right
along with us the media are just like oh
look at that nancy pelosi leader
yeah i trust you guys i trust you guys
on covet i trust you guys uncovered
relief i trust you guys on voter fraud
or i don't trust you on any of this
stuff it is it is your lack of
credibility that has led to a rise of
radical almost deconstructionist
skepticism
in the very notion that there is such a
thing as a fact or truth
you know there are a lot of people in
the media who said we live in a
post-truth era yeah you created it
you created the post-truth era if you
want uh
revision of that era if you want to go
back to a truth
how about this how about you be the
skeptics and i mean that you need to
actually check your own side
ask tough questions of nancy pelosi or
joe biden and maybe
maybe at that point somebody will start
from the right thinking they are a
credible source otherwise
shut up nobody trusts you i mean you're
ridiculous you're just ridiculous
alrighty meanwhile there's a fascinating
piece
that i think demonstrates the blindness
of the
of the left when it comes to deep
economic issues in the united states
it's a piece in the new york times today
that i want to go through in a little
bit of detail
because it really is indicative of where
we are in our current political
discourse
and it demonstrates that for so much of
our current political discourse a lot of
it is about how
members of the left simply refuse to
acknowledge that their policies have
ever failed under any circumstances ever
it's pretty impressive okay so there's a
piece in the new york times over the
weekend
called why did racial progress stall in
america
it's written by shaolin romney garrett
and robert putnam so i've recommended
robert putnam's work on the program
before robert putnam
has done some really interesting work on
isolation in america
he wrote a book called bowling alone in
which you discuss the fact that
multiculturalism and diversity might not
actually strengthen a community what
strengthens a community is a common
sense of vision
and then you can have whatever kind of
racial or ethnic diversity you want so
long as everybody shares the same kind
of common philosophy right so inside a
church you can have a very
ethnically diverse church and everything
still works perfectly
but if you have a bunch of people who
conflict on fundamental ideas then
diversity is not in fact a strength
diversity could be very divisive which
is just common sense he writes about
this in bowling alone he talks about the
death of social institutions so a lot of
his work is actually quite good robert
putnam
but this piece is really indicative of
the
tremendous blindness left has to the
impact of its own preferred government
policies
so according to this piece in the new
york times in the popular narrative of
american history
black americans made essentially no
measurable progress toward equality with
white americans until the lightning bolt
changes of the civil rights revolution
if that narrative were charted along the
course of the 20th century it would be a
flat line for decades followed by a
sharp dramatic upturn toward equality
beginning in the 60s the shape of a
hockey stick
in many ways this hockey stick image of
racial inequality is accurate
until the banning of de jure segregation
and discrimination very little progress
was made in many domains
representation in politics and
mainstream media job quality and job
security
access to professional schools and
careers or toward residential
integration
however on a number of other measures
the shape of the trend is surprisingly
different
okay this is something that i've pointed
out walter williams the late economist
late great walter williams pointed out
thomas soule has pointed this out is
that
actually black economic progress before
the civil rights act was stronger year
on year
than it was after the civil rights act
year on year in the black community
right there's a tremendous myth that has
been pervaded by the media which is that
everything sucked until the civil rights
act for black americans
and again this is correct that when it
comes to actually by law allowing
segregation that's true
you still had segregation that was
overtly practiced in the south up till
the mid 60s
but the notion that black americans were
unable to economically progress in the
united states generally and particularly
outside the south was absolutely 100 not
true
before the civil rights act right just
statistically speaking this is the point
these authors are going to make and then
they're going to completely miss the
point so they say in our book the
upswing
how america came together a century ago
and how we can do it again we examine
century-long data
tracking outcomes by race in health
education income wealth and voting what
we found surprised us
shouldn't have because it's been well
known for a long time in terms of
material well-being
black americans were moving toward
parity with white americans well before
the victories of the civil rights era
what's more after the passage of civil
rights legislation those trends toward
racial parity slowed
stopped even reversed understanding how
and why not only reveals why america is
so fractured today but illuminates the
path forward toward a more perfect union
in measure after measure according to
these authors remember these are folks
on the left
positive change for black americans was
actually faster in the decades before
the civil rights revolution
than in the decades after now by the way
this is not an argument
the civil rights revolution was bad i'm
going to explain in a second
where everything went wrong in terms of
racial inequality in the united states
because it was moving toward parity
then the civil rights revolution happens
which is definitely a good thing
and then things slow so why did they
slow their answer is wrong
their diagnosis is wrong but their their
actual but their actual description is
correct
so they point out the life expectancy
gap between black and white americans
narrowed most rapidly between 1905 and
after which the rate of improvement was
much more modest by 1995 the life
expectancy ratio
was the same as it had been in 1961.
there has been some progress in the
ensuing two decades but this is in part
due to an increase in premature deaths
among working-class whites in other
words
the white life expectancy went down it's
not that black life expectancy went up
they point out the black white ratio of
high school completion improved
dramatically between the 1940s and the
early 1970s
after which it slowed it never reaching
parity college completion followed the
same trajectory until 1970 and then
sharply reversed so black americans
more and more of them were going to
college more and more of them were
graduating high school and then we had
the 1970s and it started to reverse
racial integration in k-12 education at
the national level began
much earlier than is often believed
accelerated sharply in the wake of brown
versus board the trend leveled off in
the early 70s followed by a modest trend
toward re-segregation
also income by race converged at the
greatest race at the greatest rate
between
1940 and 1970. as of 2018
black white income disparities were
almost exactly the same as they were in
1968 50 years ago
even taking into account the emergence
of the black middle class black
americans on the whole have experienced
flat or downward mobility in recent
decades the racial gap in home ownership
steadily narrowed between 1900 and 1970
and then stagnated and then reversed the
racial wealth gap is now growing as
black home ownership plummets
run data on national trends and voting
by racist patchy the south saw a
dramatic increase in black voter
registration between 1940 and 1970
followed by decline and stagnation what
data we have on national black voter
turnout indicate nearly all the gains
toward equality with white voter turnout
occurred between 52 and 64 before the
voting rights act passed
and then almost entirely halted for the
rest of the century
these data reveal a too slow but
unmistakable climb toward racial parity
throughout most of the century that
begins to flatline around 1970
a picture quite unlike the hockey stick
of historical shorthand
okay now here is is where they go wrong
right so they get the
the description correct and then they
get the diagnosis
completely wrong because the picture
they're painting is now a much more
accurate picture which is
black income growth life expectancy
job occupancy all of these things are
rising steadily up until you hit about
and then everything flatlines reverses
so what exactly happened
here is their answer and it's wrong okay
so here is the answer of leftists who
cannot understand or liberals rather who
cannot understand that their policy
prescriptions have failed they say we
draw attention to the unexpected shape
and timing of these trends
not as an attempt to argue that things
are or were better for black americans
than they might appear
quite the contrary gains on the part of
black americans or do almost entirely so
they're fleeing the south by the
millions during the great migration
right this part is true
that if you leave the south which is
segregated and you move to chicago la
detroit
philadelphia this meant better access to
health care education and economic
opportunities
it is also true that there is a
persistent reality of exclusion
segregation and racial violence in a lot
of these places
in the last half century however
collective progress has halted many who
have fought so hard
for this progress have now lived to see
it reversed
he says it is against the these authors
say it is against this backdrop of
stillborn hopes and intergenerational
reversals that black lives matter
protesters have taken
to the streets okay and so the
implication is that things are the same
in 1968 as they were for black americans
like today which is just not true okay
it's not true legally speaking it is not
true certainly with regard to policing
so what is their explanation for why the
reversal so they have two answers
the first is simple and familiar white
backlash substantial progress toward
white support for black equality was
made in the first half of the 20th
century when push came to shove
many white americans were reluctant to
give to live up to those principles
although clear majorities supported the
1964 civil rights act a national poll
conducted shortly after its passage
showed that 68 of americans wanted
moderation in its enforcement
in fact many felt the johnson
administration was moving too fast in
implementing
integration johnson's rejection in 68 of
the colonel commission's recommendations
of sweeping reforms to address racial
inequality suggested his fine-tuned
political sensitivity had detected a sea
change in white attitudes since he
more than any other previous president
had led the project of racial redress
okay and then and he tries to compare
this to
the heels of reconstruction when there
was this big backlash against
reconstruction
in the aftermath of the civil war
okay then he he talks about the the
second
idea okay the second idea is what he
says is the i we i curve this is robert
putnam
uh and um and cheryl sorry shailene
romney garrett
he talks about the i we they talk about
the i we i curve this is
their second explanation for something
bad that happened so first is white
people got bad like in 68 suddenly
they've been getting better and then
they just got bad in 68.
and then they say there's something
called the ib i curve an inverted you
charting america's gradual climb from
self-centeredness to a sense of shared
values
followed by a steep descent back into
egoism over the next half-century ah the
soul of americans
was was completely corrupted so
basically everything sucked at the
beginning of the 20th century
then we got very community oriented
thanks to fdr and lbj
and then we reversed we went into the
greed years okay this is just a full-on
liberal narrative that happens not to be
true
these authors say the moment america
took its foot off the gas in rectifying
racial inequality
largely coincides with the moments
americans weed decades gave way to the
era of
i at the mid 60s peak of the eyewey
curve long delayed moves toward racial
inclusion had raised hopes for further
improvements but those hopes went
unrealized as the whole nation shifted
toward a less egalitarian ideal
a central feature of america's i decades
has been a shift away from shared
responsibilities toward individual
rights and a culture of narcissism
economic inequality has skyrocketed
along with it have come massive
disparities in political influence
a growing concentration of political
economic power in the hands of a few
billionaires now here's why this is so
ridiculous on an economic level the
government is way bigger than it was in
the 60s like way bigger
regulations are significantly more
restrictive in many areas of american
life now than they were back in the
1960s because we have literally hundreds
of thousands of pages of regulations
that have been promulgated
ever since the government has never
spent more money than it is right now we
are spending four trillion
dollars a year so this idea that you are
now freer than you ever were
economically in the united states is
just
not true but say these authors
the lessons of america's i we i century
are thus twofold
first the americans have gotten
ourselves out of a mess remarkably
similar to the one we're in now by
rediscovering the spirit of community
that has defined our nation from its
inception
we turn the tide from idaho we once
before and we can do it again
but we can be defined in more inclusive
or exclusive terms we have to be more
inclusive
in the definition of we okay so all of
this ignores what actually happened in
the 1960s and 70s so it actually
happened in the 1960s and 70s is there
is a building momentum
inside the united states an excellent
great momentum
toward racial equality in law right the
basic idea was going to be that everyone
was going to be given the same
opportunities of the declaration
independence and the constitution of the
united states
everyone would be finally given the
guarantees of the 14th amendment equal
protection under law
and racism would be officially abolished
there would be no government programs
that were explicitly designed along the
basis of race
and those opportunities would be open
okay the story of struggle of black
americans
triumphantly moving toward racial
progress
and economic progress in the face of
actual legal barriers is just i mean
it's an unbelievable story of bravery
and greatness
over the beginning of the the end of
from the civil end of the civil war
to 1965 and then by 1970 everything is
reversing
why it is not because american souls
suddenly
were were put on the back burner because
americans suddenly became selfish again
or something like that
and it is not because uh it is not
because of quote unquote white backlash
where white people who had literally
just said okay how about this how about
we actually get rid of all this
discrimination and law they're like you
know what now that we did that we're
going to discriminate
there's another possibility and the
possibility is there was a very change
in the definition
of what constituted racial
discrimination in the united states
there's a point that shelby steele has
made
it's when christopher caldwell has made
in his book the age of entitlement
okay the change in definition was made
by lbj himself
the change in definition was instead of
racial equality being provided under law
in other words the law cannot
discriminate against you instead
racial equality would be enforced by law
racial equality and outcome
right lyndon baines johnson suggested
that the goal was not
to simply make the playing field level
the point was to push people who had
historically been behind
up to the starting line of the race he
said this in a very famous speech at
howard university
was it's just unfair because there are
people who are behind and they're people
who are ahead
thanks to historical influences and the
only way for us to make things fair
again is to now discriminate against the
people who are ahead in favor of the
people who are behind
and that's where you get a backlash
right that's when the government starts
to actually impose policies
that are not about enforcing equality of
rights
but instead enforcing a government a
government idea of what equality of
outcome
would look like so one example of this
is forest busting which by the way
wildly unpopular in both white
communities and black communities as it
turns out by opinion polling
from the 1970s so instead of saying okay
every kid has to have equal access to
the local school
in the neighborhood in which they live
instead they say you know what we're
looking for a specific racial mix and in
order to do that we're going to bus your
kid
to a particular school that is not in
your community outside of your started
in boston by the way
outside of your community and parents
went you know what i don't want my kid
to be part of a social experiment i want
my kid to go to school where
i live and if people live in my
neighborhood and they want to go to
school they're great but i'm not sending
my kid all the way across the city
to teachers in a school i don't know
with kids i don't know and spending an
hour and a bus every morning i'm moving
out to the suburbs
and so you get white flight out of
cities like boston is that racism so the
left would say of course that's racism
that's the evils of the american soul
or is that just parents being parents
and protecting their kids being used in
social experimentation
i wouldn't blame black parents for doing
that i wouldn't blame white parents for
doing that i wouldn't blame any parent
for doing that because you're a parent
as a parent your goal
is to protect your child and get them
the best available educational
opportunity
the best way to if you want to preserve
integration in public schools
you let the schools be local and you let
black kids go to the local school
whether it is white or black and you let
white kids go to the local school
whether it is white or black so forced
bussing is a good example
of how the government tried to cram down
on popular policy
and it ended up achieving exactly the
reverse of what government wanted to do
the same thing is true
when it came to welfare programs that
were put in place by the lbj
administration
the johnson administration suddenly
started suggesting that there were
positive rights right rights to housing
rights to a job
rights to certain levels of remuneration
right that there was going to be welfare
payments that were made on the basis
of single motherhood and you suddenly
see the single motherhood rate start to
skyrocket
in 1960 the single motherhood rate in
the black community was 20 today it's in
excess of 70
there's a reason for that the reason for
that is government policy
in fact if you look all the way back to
the early 20th century black americans
had a higher rate of marriage than white
americans did
this is not a cultural thing this is a
government policy created thing
so the mistake that was made in the
1960s was not the pursuit
of racial equality under law it was the
pursuit of racial equality
as an outcome under the law which meant
the direct application of inequality
between citizens
right that was the backlash it did
create a backlash
it not only created a backlash it also
undermined the
very sort of equal standard that
promulgates good living
right because it turns out if you pay
people to do bad things decision wise
they will do bad things
decision wise but the left believes the
government is always the solution right
so the problem is they can never
acknowledge that these government
programs were a failure
they can never acknowledge that the war
on poverty has been an extraordinary
failure
we've spent tens of trillions of dollars
in various war on poverty programs
and the poverty rate is about the same
now as it was back when they were first
started
the racial inequality rates are about
the same now as they were back when
government first tried to get in the
business of guaranteeing an equal
outcome
government should never have been in the
business of trying to guarantee an equal
outcome
government's only mandate is equal
justice under law that is the only
mandate
okay and that mandate which suggests
that there is a regime of rights and
that if you properly exercise those
rights and you ought to be protected in
those rights by the government
that you have a fair shot at success
that's what government should have been
doing
so what these sociologists are missing
of course is the most basic point of all
which is that when you incentivize
people differently then you get
different outcomes
when take housing for example when you
shift the nature of housing from
you're not allowed to discriminate in
public housing
two we are going to subsidize particular
types of housing in particular types of
community regardless of the financial
straits of those communities
you are not in fact solving the
underlying problems
right this is what happened with the
subprime mortgage crisis in the in the
2000s
that was directly related to the
community reinvestment act
it was directly related to the fact that
the federal government was subsidizing
subprime mortgages to people who did not
have good credit
credit scores and it turns out when the
real estate market started to tank
a lot of those people could not pay
their debts were those people being done
a favor they were not being done a favor
okay again remember those stats home
ownership gaps between blacks and whites
were actually narrowing between 1900 and
and now black home ownership has been
plummeting that is a result of
government policy it's not a result
of selfishness or cruelty that's a
result of government policy that is not
directed
at incentivizing behavior that leads to
homeownership particularly
treat people the same under law and you
will get similar behavior from people
under law
treat people differently under law and
you'll get people being treated
differently under law this has been true
throughout human history it will
continue to be true and until the left
recognizes this gaps are going to
continue to increase
they're not going to decrease and all of
these
all of these supposedly compassionate
liberals who believe that government can
come in and solve all these problems and
create equality of outcome
they're doing precisely the reverse of
what they tried to do
and they're making the country worse in
the process because they're implying
that if you oppose those programs then
you are not quote unquote anti-racist
right their whole idea here is that if
you believe in equality of rights before
the law
this makes you a bad person right this
is the ibrahim kendi thing this is the
robin d'angelo thing
this is all the morons in the media who
keep saying anti-racist when they
actually mean
is you oppose the complete destruction
of equal justice before law
abram kennedy openly says the only
answer to injustices of the past are
injustices today
he overtly calls for the end of the
individual right
in the name of collective outcomes and
that is what is being pushed right now
and there should be a backlash against
that because it's un-american not only
is it not american it is utterly
unproductive and it does not
not only unify americans it also
creates more inequality and effect and
the the fact that the
liberals refuse to recognize this and
the fact that the evidence is staring
them right in the face
right in the face and they just refuse
to recognize it it truly is
an incredible incredible thing alrighty
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you
here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by nico
geneva the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production
copyright daily wire 2020 president
trump stumps to keep control of the
senate in georgia
the supreme court helps the president's
election challenge and business owners
have had enough of california's tyrants
check it out on the michael knowles show
you